das teils gespräch bei phoenix mit dem
spitzenkandidaten der fti group
allergrößte sie ganz herzlich in ihrer
heimatstadt weißwasser hallo guten
morgen also mortons du es gescheitert
damit ist auch dass du neue group aller
gescheitert an der parteispitze
nein das sehe ich nicht zu vermelden hat
seine aufgabe in brüssel ist erst
gespräche hat dort zuständig in berlin
ich bin spitzenkandidaten mit frau
weiter für die bundestagswahl also die
rollen sind klar verteilt
ja gut die roten sind verteilt aber der
co-vorsitzende hat ja nicht gerade mit
werbung für sie geglänzt
oder vielleicht könne anders formulieren
ja ich hätte mir sehr wohl gewünscht
dass herr wollten sich ein bisschen als
sprecher der neutralität verpflichtet
gefühlt hat er nicht getan er hat sich
für ein anderes duo entschieden hat es
beworben die mitglieder haben
entschieden und das hat auch am meisten
zu respektieren 71 prozent ist denke ich
doch ein strömungs übergreifendes gutes
ergebnis und damit können wir es
gemeinschaftlich auch in den wahlkampf
ziehen
und er wird auch erneuten sich daran
beteiligen was schon ein bisschen
eigenartig oder wenn der co na gut lass
mir dass wir waren gar nicht so viel
jetzt über herrn leuten reden sondern
über sie und ihre co spitzenkandidatin
und über ihre partei umbruch in der
partei heißt es bei diesem wahlergebnis
noch mal ich habe es jetzt schwierig
verstanden heißt dieses ergebnis von 71
prozent
es gibt jetzt also einen klaren umbruch
in der afd also wenn man 71 prozent
zustimmung hat kann es ja keinen umbruch
geben im gegenteil ist ein sehr einigen
das ergebnis wir mit frau weitere haben
immer betont dass wir auch alle
strömungen dieser partei abbilden und
natürlich auch mitnehmen wollen das tue
ich als fraktionsvize und auch als
parteisprecher frau weigel als
fraktionsvorsitzende wir arbeiten und
sehr integrativ zusammen sagen wir der
bundestagsfraktion bewiesen und ich auch
als parteisprecher und das haben auch
die mitglieder kotiert und deswegen
freue ich mich auf diesen
gemeinschaftlichen wahlkampf jetzt mit
frau weigel ja sagen wahrscheinlich
andere auch in ihrer partei es ist ja
schon auch eine gewisse
partei und eine flügelbildung da ich
weiß flügel ist ein schwieriger begriff
aber die unterstützer liegen wenn sie
dann bei ihnen so versammelt sind ist
das ja schon auch ein signal auch in die
partie rein oder wissen sie das ist mehr
oder weniger für die medien interessant
für die mitglieder hat sich um keinen
ausdruck gebracht dass hier eine gewisse
lagerkampf da ist sie haben sich für
diejenigen entschieden die auch derzeit
die partei repräsentieren und das werden
wir im wahlkampf touren also von daher
ist das auch für den von ihnen derzeit
ein bisschen überbewertet und so sehen
wir das aktuell also gibt es keine
richtungsdebatte ich glaube schon oder
wie wäre doch dann jetzt vorbei wissen
sie wir haben nein die gibt nämlich die
wie wollen sie natürlich gerne
hervorziehen das ist für sie für die
medien immer sehr interessant wir haben
einen enden wahlprogramm verabschiedet
mit sehr großer mehrheit mit fast 100
prozent auf dem dresdner parteitag
wir haben kontrovers diskutiert das
gehört in eine pluralistische partei
dazu das ist auch die kontroversen
debatten kommt das ist das lebt da
verlebt die die afd das zeichnet
eigentlich auch die afg aus das haben
wir anderen parteien in weit voraus dass
bei uns die mitglieder sehr kontrovers
streiten und am ende einigen wir uns auf
ein programm das machen wir in der
bundestagsfraktion aber genauso auf den
parteitagen und dem fühle ich mich
verpflichtet auch als bundessprecher und
deswegen werden wir auch dieses programm
mit dem wahlkampf zu verteidigen und das
heißt er auch also das jetzt nicht eine
erfindung von mir wahrscheinlich wieder
die medien dass der flügel das
wahlprogramm doch maßgeblich mitbestimmt
hat stimmt das nicht
bei uns bestimmen die mitglieder das
wahlprogramm mit dem züge wie sie wissen
gibt sich mit der iss ausgelöst worden
der existiert nicht mehr also von daher
haben wir uns die mitglieder dieses
wahlprogramm beschlossen und auch fast
einstimmig beschlossen und von daher
stellt sich diese frage überhaupt nicht
das ist eigentlich das große thema mit
dem sie punkten wollen mit dem sie
polarisieren können ist dass das was wir
gestern auch gesagt haben bei der
pressekonferenz eu reformieren ansonsten
raus der eu ist er sicherlich jetzt kein
thema für die bundestagswahl allein wer
stellen natürlich sehr wohl die soziale
frage in den mittelpunkt aber auch die
die wirtschaftspolitischen themen die
wir natürlich jetzt grad nachgeholt
aber auch jetzt aktuell noch mit der
korona krise hier in den mittelpunkt
stellen
wir müssen uns anschauen wie die
wirtschaft weiter erodiert wir sehen
dass viele firmenpleiten jetzt ins haus
stehen
das eine große inflationswelle auch das
ist ja aktuell ein großes thema hier ins
haus steht das lieferketten unterbrochen
sind nicht nur durch corona sondern auch
durch aktuelle rohstoffmangel
materialmangel im handwerk mittelstand
sind das große probleme den wollen wir
uns natürlich auch programmatisch
entgegenstellen und wollen natürlich
auch lösungen aufzeigen welche denn
zum beispiel wenn wir den mittelstand
uns betrachten was aktuell die co2
steuer angeht die eingeführt wurde wo
wir auch klar sagen diese gehört
abgeschafft die grünen wollen diese
sogar noch bis auf 60 euro pro tonne
erhöhen
das bedeutet für eine vierköpfige
familie mehrbelastungen energiebereich
aber auch in ausgaben auf grad für die
pendler im ländlichen raum von bis zu
1400 euro für eine vierköpfige familie
da frage ich mich ganz ehrlich wie
sollen das eigentlich die bürger in
zukunft noch bezahlen und deswegen
fordern wir auch bezahlbare energie und
hier muss im prinzip auch der staat
dafür sorge tragen dass das
gewährleistet wird also eher ein
sozialstaat
beides muss sich die waage halten eine
starke wirtschaft bedingt einen guten
sozialstaat und das ist genau unsere
programmatik es kann nicht nur soziales
geben ist ganz klar aber die
leistungserbringer diejenigen die wert
schöpfen in diesem land arbeiten
handwerk mittelstand die 14 15 millionen
die diesen ganzen laden das ganze land
am laufen halten die müssen ein stück
weit entlastet werden und die müssen
auch gewürdigt werden die müssen mit 40
stunden arbeit die woche auch davon
leben können und diejenigen die ihre
lebensleistung erbracht haben müssen
nach 40 jahren arbeit von ihrer rente
leben können ohne sozialleistungen zu
erbringen oder beziehungsweise vom staat
erleben zu müssen damit entlasten wir
sogar den sozialstaat
gut also dass hören wir von anderen
ähnlich aber sie haben ja gesagt sie
wollen stärker werden als die spd und
werden wir jetzt mal bei der spd den
kanzlerkandidaten zitieren 25 plus hat
er glaube ich gesagt müssten sie dann
auch mindestens 25 liefern
mit welchem thema können sie das
wirklich wir haben gerade einige themen
in genannt in 25 prozent halte ich für
utopisch was die spd da als wahlziel
genannt
ja es ist für uns ist es wichtig dass
wir als wahlziel sicherlich ein starkes
und stärkeres ergebnis als 2017 wollen
neben der sozialen frage ob die
wirtschaftlichen dinge natürlich gerade
aber auch natürlich die reformierung der
eu die wir ja auch in unserem
wahlprogramm forciert haben wir haben
ein starkes sozial und renten papier
verabschiedet schon anfang des jahres
als es sind die themen mit dem wir
natürlich punkten wollen dass wir
denjenigen die den leistungserbringern
ich habe es erwähnt in diesem land
natürlich diese entlasten wollen wir
wollen aber auch für die familie da sein
wir wollen auch alleinerziehenden ein
angebot machen dass die sie sich in
diesem land auch wohlfühlen und dass die
sich auch weiterhin gewertschätzt fühlen
können wir noch ganz kurz zum schluss
weil es da ein dissens gibt anscheinend
auf die außenpolitik gucken es gab ja
nun beschlüsse für sanktionen in
richtung belarus und da gibt es den
dissens zwischen freidl die krise
kritisiert diese sanktionen und herrn
gauland der sagt ja das ist vollkommen
richtig weil das piraterie ist wo stehen
sie
ich denke da gibt es keinen großen
bisschen sv weiler hat natürlich per se
die sanktion an die sanktionspolitik an
sich kritisiert weil wir haben ja in der
vergangenheit gesehen da muss man sich
die frage stellen inwieweit sanktionen
in der aussenpolitik überhaupt was
bewirken
ich denke die treffen belarus in dieser
weise überhaupt nicht man muss sich
genau natürlich anschauen was die
vorgesehen ist dort sind da ich bin
immer für den dialog das gleiche trifft
im übrigens mit der ukraine und auch in
russland konflikt zu dialog ist wichtig
wir wollen hier keine keine keiner
hochschaukeln und ein krisen konflikt
der im endeffekt vielleicht in einem
krieg mündet das kann nicht unser ziel
sein auch nicht in europa weil wir klar
ganz klar auch als auf die sagt nie
wieder krieg noch dazu in europa und
deswegen ist für mich der dialog wichtig
auch wenn es mit schwierigen regierung
sicherlich nicht immer einfach ist
sanktionspolitik denke ich wird wenig
bewirken sagt timo grub aller der
co-vorsitzende der afg und kandidat
spitzenkandidat für die bundestagswahl
dankeschön dass ihr zeit für uns hatten
sehr gern